- I love the Weekender!
(audience applauding)
All right,
let's give everyone a
fresh crop of things to do
this weekend,
and I'll kick it off with
a great app to download.
It's called Storyteller.
If you wake up with 100
social media notifications,
but would rather start your
day with one positive thought,
provoking a daily
affirmation, get this app.
It's curated by the
amazing poet and artist,
Morgan Harper Nichols,
and she shares encouraging
words every morning,
and beautiful artwork like this one.
No matter what, you will grow,
and it's the perfect addition
to your morning coffee.
Okay. Next, I've got
something to listen to.
It's a podcast called Sleep with Me.
It sounds racy, but it's
literally the opposite.
The whole point of this
very boring podcast,
is to put you to sleep.
It's narrated by Drew Scooter Ackerman,
who bores you to bed with a
short form story or a TV recap,
and each episode lasts an hour,
but you'll only need about 20-
(snoring)
Oh, hi.
(audience laughing)
It's good. It works.
And to watch,
we have to go with "America's
Funniest Home Videos",
because it's an American classic.
And guess who is on the show?
I am so excited because today
we have a very special guest.
He made us laugh for decades,
from "Silver Spoons",
to "The Fresh Prince",
and now he's been hosting
"America's Funniest Home Videos"
for six years.
It's someone I've actually
known since I was a kid.
Alfonso Ribeiro!
(audience cheering)
- Hey, how are you, Drew?
- Okay. It must have been
somewhere around like '83,
'84 when we met?
- Yes. "Night of 100 Stars
II", was when we first met,
back when you were doing,
obviously, "E.T.", and yeah.
Like I've watched you
grow through the years.
You're doing awesome.
Congratulations on your
show, it's beautiful.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
I mean, Alfonso,
I remember going to the
set of "Silver Spoons".
- Right, yep. You would come.
- Yeah, absolutely, and with The Ricker.
Thank you.
(Alfonso laughing)
- Yes, The Ricker. I haven't
heard that in a long time.
It's been awhile since I've
heard someone refer to him,
as The Ricker.
- I know, I know.
(audience laughing)
'Cause I met him doing a
cover of People Magazine,
and it was like, you know,
the fresh crop, or you know,
who's gonna make it out
alive in this photograph,
kind of a thing.
(audience laughing)
And then I knew you in and around,
and then we were both like
in the Corey Feldman circle.
- That's, wow. You do remember it all.
Yes.
I wasn't gonna bring up
the Corey Feldman circle,
but yes, we were part of the
Corey Feldman, circle of crazy.
- Oh yeah.
(audience laughing)
No, I remember hanging out
with you in like his kitchen,
and just getting to be around you,
and I always liked you so much,
and you were always so like, cool.
- Well, you were a sweet little girl,
who has now turned into an
amazing young woman, still.
And we had fun. We had
fun back in the day.
We were kids in a business that, you know,
wasn't always very kind to us all,
and you know, to be able
to make it out of that,
and remain level-headed,
and be able to continue
doing what we love to do.
Like how many people get to say, you know,
I had my 40th anniversary
in the business last year,
and that's insane to me,
(audience applauding)
like 40 years being able
to do what we love to do,
and just be in this
business, is very special.
- And I mean, "America's
Funniest Home Videos"
is such an institution.
- Yes, we're on our 31st season,
my sixth season as host.
(audience applauding)
I get to follow legends like
Tom Bergeron and Bob Saget.
You know, listen, I feel like
every day it's such an honor
that I get to actually host
that show, especially right now.
Like we all need to laugh,
and "America's Funniest Home Videos"
continues to bring silly
laughter into people's homes,
week in and week out, and you know,
no matter how many times you see someone
get hit in the crotch, it's still funny.
It's still funny.
(audience laughing)
- It's true. When things go awry, I laugh.
I know it's wrong, but I do it.
- Well, see, we make sure, you know,
I always tell people,
you got like a split second to make sure,
when someone falls down
and hurts themselves,
you're like, okay, did they
really hurt themselves?
No. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
Then full rights to go
ahead and laugh at them,
but they just got to make sure
that they didn't like
break a bone or something,
before you laugh.
- It's the one second rule.
- Split second.
- Yes. Right. The one second.
One second, they okay? They're
all right. You can laugh.
You're good.
(audience laughing)
- Alfonso, just the best
thing in the world to see you,
really.
- You too. You too.
So happy.
Thanks for having me on and
being able to chat with you,
and catch up, and we'll do a bunch more.
- Yay!
(audience cheering)
Oh, yay.
And before we go,
I have quick pick from
The Little Yellow Book.
That's right,
(audience applauding)
it's my weekly list of stuff
that I have to share with you.
This week, this is Blueland,
a company I have been obsessed
with since it came out,
and this, you get a
starter kit for $20 bucks.
You get the powder, you
mix it with the water.
There's this really
feel-good, silicone bottle.
And there you go.
You are eco-friendly, kissing the earth,
and cleaning your hands and dishes.
They have got everything.
Check them out at,
blueland.com
but all of that will be on our website,
thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
And that, is your Weekender.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)